foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome everybody this is
seafar's first ever hybrid virtual talk
event and we're here live at Mila in
Montreal and also streamed live uh
online
a gemapella list of strong I am the
executive director of the pan Canadian
AI strategy at seafar and we'd like to
begin today by acknowledging that Mila
is located on unseated indigenous
landsega nation is recognized as the
custodians of the lands and Waters on
which We Gather today
or Montreal is historically known as a
Gathering Place for many First Nations
today it is home to a diverse population
of indigenous and other peoples we
respect and admire the continued
connections with the past president and
future in our ongoing relationships with
indigenous and other peoples within the
Montreal community
Mila and sifar acknowledge the systemic
barriers that indigenous people face
with respect to education employment
land and Technology
indigenous knowledge and science have
typically been devalued excluded and
erased from AI science and therefore we
recognize the need for a commitment to
work with indigenous peoples in AI
research and Science and both sifa and
Mila are actively working in the space
and I'd be happy to talk to anybody
after today's event about some of the
initiatives that we have
I want to invite our audiences online as
well uh to reflect on the lands that
they are joining us from
and I also want to acknowledge that last
night was the start of Ramadan and want
to wish Ramadan Mubarak to those who are
marking it
so let's get started uh as part of
cfar's 40th anniversary celebration this
event is uh one of a series of virtual
talks that we've been hosting throughout
the year
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
global research organization that
convenes extraordinary Minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and Humanity the pan Canadian AI
strategy at seafar drives Cutting Edge
research trains the next generation of
diverse AI leaders and fosters
cross-sectoral collaboration for
Innovation commercialization and
responsible AI adoption our three
National AI institutes these are Amy and
Edmonton the vector Institute in Toronto
and Mila here in Montreal are the
vibrant Central hubs of Canada's
thriving AI ecosystem
funded by the government of Canada we're
building a dynamic representative and
Rich community of world leading
researchers who are creating
transformative responsible AI solutions
for people in the planet
so it is my distinct pleasure to
introduce you to our two speakers for
today's talk on AI agents amongment
Among Us with a deep dive into causality
and reinforcement learning so first we
have donya sridhar Donya is a Canada
cfar AI chair at Mila and an assistant
professor at the department of computer
science and operations research uh
affectionately known as dyro at the
University of Montreal she develops
Theory and machine learning methods to
study causal questions causal questions
are about interventions to the world how
would patients respond if they were
given a new therapeutic what is the
effect of a new content moderation
policy on social media posts so thinking
about cause and effect is where Donya
spends much of her time
also joining us is Mark belmare Mark is
a Canada C4 AI chair at Mila AC far
associate fellow in our learning and
machines and brains program and an agile
an adject professor at the school of
computer science at McGill University
and a research scientist at Google brain
in Montreal
his long-term goal is the design of
generally competent agents agents that
can successfully operate in a wide range
of environments and eventually exhibit
the gamut of behavior that we attribute
to humans including things like
curiosity boredom competence and
emergent communication
so today's session will last
approximately one hour and for those in
the room you're welcome to stay and
enjoy the refreshments uh after uh after
this session I'm going to get the
conversation started up here uh and
later on we'll open it up to the floor
and also to those joining us on Zoom to
bring your questions to our speakers uh
our cfar staff member Kira will be
moderating on behalf of the online
audience
uh and our in-person audience will have
an opportunity to ask questions directly
from your seat raise your hand I'll call
on you and we'll we'll get the
microphone to you directly at your seat
and the last thing to mention is that
this session is being recorded and will
be available on the cfar website next
week so let's kick it off
I'll ask each of you to tell me about
your research areas this is of course
causality for Donya and reinforcement
learning for Mark and how you got
interested in these questions Donya give
us get us started
great can you hear me
great you can still hear me okay super
um so thank you for the wonderful
introduction it is a pleasure to be here
with with you Alyssa and definitely with
you Mark I'm looking forward to learning
a lot from from you today
um so my field of research as Alyssa
mentioned is broadly the intersection of
causality and machine learning so what's
causality
and I find it very useful to start with
an example and let's take the example
that Alyssa mentioned so
um suppose we are clinicians and we want
to understand whether or not to
administer a new therapeutic or a New
Drug in order to treat a disease
we probably all have this intuition that
we would take this action this
intervention of giving a patient a drug
if it had a causal effect on recovery so
but what does that mean mathematically
it means that all else being equal if we
were to intervene and give patients this
therapeutic then we would see a change
in their chances of recovery
so that's what causality means
intuitively and as a framework the field
of causality provides a mathematical
language to take that kind of scientific
question and turn it into a mathematical
question that we can then draw
conclusions using a variety of different
assumptions and data
so a lot of the advances in the field of
causality has to do with both the
mathematical tools to Define causal
questions but also Theory and methods to
be able to draw conclusions from them
even from non-interventional data
so that's very surprising that sometimes
we can actually do causal inference
without doing experiments explicitly
and so that has been a lot of the
success of that field and why I was
drawn to the field of causality has to
do with I was doing a lot of
collaborative research with broadly
scientists both in the Life Sciences as
well as in the social sciences
and especially my social science
collaborators had a lot of challenges
that inherently are not amenable to
experimentation and they of course have
a lot of causal questions
they want to understand the effects on
people's behavior of a variety of
interventions everything from how they
change their responses depending on the
kinds of linguistic Styles they're
exposed to in a conversation uh all the
way to a variety of questions in
economics for example with collaborators
we worked on the effects of texting on
voter mobilization
and in all these fields what's really
interesting is experimentation is not
possible but there are other signals
that we can leverage to potentially do
causal imprints and the difficulty is
making use of the very rich data that we
collect
like text and images and videos and so
forth and that brings in the need for
machine learning methods so why I kind
of got very excited about this field is
both to want to make methods
computational methods that can
contribute to these fields these
scientific fields
and noticing that there's a great
opportunity in being able to use machine
learning methods to extract variables
and information using the kinds of Rich
High dimensional data that we're often
used to working within machine learning
like text and images
so that's a little bit about my
background amazing thank you Dania for
for sharing that that with us and Mark
over to you tell us about your research
and how you got into it sure it's a
great pleasure to see all of you so many
families faces in the audience today and
hello
um folks who are online as well so I
work in reading personal learning and I
like to say that today reinforcement
learning is a branch of AI that studies
how we can turn data into decisions
um essentially reimbursement learning
the name comes from has its rules in
psychology
and so if you're familiar with uh you
know classic experiments from the field
of psychology whether it's uh training
rats to find food in a maze uh or maybe
putting cash in in front of a puzzle and
asking the cat to solve this puzzle what
happened in the late 70s is that the
pioneers of reinforcement learning
Richard Sutton Andy barter and Harry
klopp actually looked at how they could
turn these ideas from psychology into
computational ideas how do we actually
uh describe the learning process of a
rat navigating a maze in a computer like
using computational operations and uh so
the field that's developed with this
idea that we want to build learning
agents that from trial and error can can
go about and explore the world and
discover how to best uh you know operate
a network what is finding food or uh or
maybe driving a car or whatever it might
be
um and so now today I think the field
has grown quite a bit and we've we've
actually moved away a little bit from
animal learning but this is still a core
part of the problem and also now we look
at uh what it might look like if we just
had a fixed amount of data what we would
call offline reinforcement learning a
fixed amount of data for example
clinical data and try to make decisions
right so the way to that I like to
separate this from sort of the more
classical machine learning approach
where we might have this data and the
data is essentially a pair of inputs and
labels right here's an image is this a
cat or a dog
well when real personal learning I say
here's an image what should you do right
an option that requires reasoning about
the outcomes and it requires everything
about time and and reward
um
and so that's why in some sense it's a
much more challenging problem but it's
also much more satisfying problem to
work on as a researcher I actually
started in reinforcement learning during
my undergrad I was very interested in AI
research already the time I was very
lucky to work with a professor here at
Mila during the breakup
um who took me on for an answer
undergraduate research
job in the summer and what I did that
summer is actually implemented a
re-implemented uh an older piece of work
that applied reinforcement learning to
backgammon play okay so the game of
backgammon is a game where it says
classic board game that involves Dice
and pieces and scoring points and uh and
so in the 90s Jerry tazoro had
demonstrated we could use reimbursement
learning to essentially become
superhuman at background and so I did I
worked on this project over the summer
and for me I think the point where I
said that's what I'm going to do for the
rest of my life was the data that had
programmed this thing and had been
training I think it took a few a few
days a few days of non-stop playing
backgammon by trial and error to learn
what it means to be a good background
player and uh you know in my spare time
I'd actually written an interface I
could play that bag I'm an agent and it
beat me there you go and at that point I
thought okay I have to keep working on
this and so that's that's how I got into
it beautiful what a lovely story
um so the title of our talk today AI
agents Among Us causality and
reinforcement learning let's talk about
what it is that we mean when we talk
about intelligent agents and what is it
that we want them to achieve
Mark let's start with you sure so I
think there's a there's actually a
spectrum of things we might want from
from Agents I'm curious to hear Daniel
stuff about this as well but certainly
uh you know at one end of the spectrum
we want these agents to be making
decisions for us completely autonomously
but that's actually quite challenging
and of course it's going to bring up a
lot of questions of trust and Safety and
Security
uh The Other Extreme we might just have
them recommend decisions right they
might go to a clinician and say I think
you should do this and leaving the
decision completely in the hand with
attention but either way I think when we
talk about agency we're we're asking
these agents to
look at the world look at the data and
say this is what I would do and maybe do
it itself or assist us in making those
choices
I love that perspective and I will Echo
and mirror a lot of the things that you
said
I think that
my sort of vision is agents that behave
like scientists that learn definitely
from Human Experience other agents
experience as well as their own
experimentation in the world
but not only use data but reasoning also
to make decisions that give us good
outcomes in a broad variety of contexts
and I'll tackle I tack on that last bit
to kind of emphasize that we would like
these policies or decisions or
interventions that they come up with to
work in a broad range of context and be
robust
and
um maybe just to kind of take the
personalized medicine that you you sort
of alluded to Mark as an example
I really like examples I find that with
causality it might really help us
understand the challenges uh we can
imagine for example a an agent that is
asked to make personalized
recommendations based on a variety of
sleep and activity and other kind of
tracking that it that is available to it
and let's say that in the case of my
personal tracking I have an agent and I
wanted to recommend strategy that I can
use to sleep better
and let's say that in my data it just so
happens that
um the days that I choose to go for a
long run are correlated with the days
that I have a really heavy breakfast
and on those same days I also sleep
really well
right
there's one version of a very naive
agent that might use this spurious
Association and then start recommending
to me to eat really heavy breakfasts and
you know go out go out to my favorite
Diner and gorge on poutine every morning
in order to sleep well
right and we don't want that
and in fact it's
not just enough for humans for agents to
learn from Human experiences and data
there may be human agents that are that
are sensitive to these kinds of spurious
associations as well we want agents that
can both build models based on the data
that they collect but also have tools
and engines to reason with about these
kinds of spurious associations and
moreover have the ability to infer
conclusions that hold in a wide variety
of points I'm curious Daniel you
you mentioned this this idea that the
intelligent agent should separate cause
and correlation right and then you know
don't eat poutine before you go to sleep
um
I'm curious you know are there studies
do humans do this well
you know are humans able to do this very
well or do you think that causal
learning can actually help us break free
from some of the patterns that we see in
human learning that's a that's a
wonderful question and I would I would
say that for example some of the
workplaces one of the Arenas in which we
apply decision-making agents already is
in the criminal justice system and in
particular in the U.S for example
um these days algorithms are what are
used to make pre-trial decisions
and in that case there has been some
very compelling evidence that in fact
because they were trained on data from
potentially very biased judges these
algorithms in fact do reproduce some
very harmful decision-making patterns
and so I think
that combined with a myriad evidence
from psychology that humans in fact do
use all sorts of shortcuts and
heuristics whenever possible
we are probably very likely to confuse
correlation for causation often
um but with the right
both inferential tools as well as
reasoning tools like there's maybe a
chance for agents to be able to do
better
is there a way that these tools can I'm
assuming it's going to depend on the
data that you have whether you can do
more than just local correlations right
or is there is it always possible to do
more than correlation that's a that's a
that's a great question and
I think in fact we can maybe look to
some of the the results in
fully inferring causal models from raw
data that are a bit negative in terms of
being able to learn from observational
data alone right so just to be a bit
more concrete if you wanted to with the
data that we passively collect infer all
of the cause and effect relationships
that govern a particular system
this is basically impossible without
some experimentation
and so this is where actually I think
Mark
um this brings us to then the field of
RL because the
theory of causality suggests that
without some amount of
intervention and agents acting in the
world it is not actually possible to
learn causal models so I think what's
exciting then is to think about how
agents can learn most effectively from
the perhaps limited amount of
interaction they have with the world and
in particular embodied agents that don't
necessarily get to manipulate absolutely
everything in the system
um
and I think that brings us into more the
realm of RL which is where I think maybe
those insights can actually really help
the field of fidelity
yeah so there's actually a sub deal the
reinforcement I think called exploration
that I've worked on that is essentially
exactly tries to get that question of if
I need fresh data
what should I do to collect it right if
I if I
um you know sometimes it can be very
easy I I am curious to try out new
restaurants in Montreal how do I go
about finding a new restaurant I haven't
tried out well I could just have a list
and say I haven't tried at this
restaurant I might want to be a bit more
you know refined and say uh you know
I've added up Canadian Cuisines lately
so I'm going to try a different kind of
restaurant
um
for some of these things we know how to
do this the reality is to this day I
think we have a very poor understanding
still of how to you said you know most
efficiently collect that data uh I wish
we had solutions for you but we don't
have them today we're working on this
actively uh and I think one challenge is
when you go to to problems where there's
a lot more input variables right then it
becomes it's sort of a bit of a chicken
and egg problem you'd like to try out
new things but you have all these input
variables and you don't know how to
relate to each other and so how do you
decide what to try first you don't know
the relationship
and uh you know eventually we know how
to do this in very simple problems where
we can say for example I'm navigating a
room I want to discover the structure of
the room well let's that's something we
understand pretty well I'm going to just
roam around the room and then when I'm
done I'm done
um but now imagine for example
um if you had a a robotic hand
manipulator right like directly that's a
much more complicated problem to say
what does it mean to explore the space
of configuration that is hand might take
um
and you can imagine that in problems
where this there's both a lot of input
variables and also where it's costly to
get that data that trade-off becomes
quite difficult
that's very interesting that you say
that because I would say in fact this is
maybe also one of the profound
challenges of making causality more
broadly applicable in decision making
and scientific applications
um a lot of the theory has been
developed in settings where the
variables that we would like to reason
about in a system are directly measured
for us or rather we we begin at the
point at which we have variables
um and in a lot of the kinds of problems
that clinicians work on or in safety
critical applications like self-driving
or in spaces that social scientists work
in that's not the kind of data we
collect we collect raw sort of inputs
that maybe humans are more used to
working with like visual inputs and
language inputs and it is
a challenge to process those kinds of
high dimensional complex inputs into
variables that we can then build causal
reasoning on top of
um
I don't know if that resonates with you
mark uh as one of the challenges in RL
as well yeah it does and I think you
know to look at the clinical example
again I also suppose
um
if we were to to say collect clinical
data from a doctor working with their
patients and you know making choices
about their treatment I think one
challenge is also that often what's
recorded in the data is actually a very
small subset of the actual variables you
know that they use to make those
decisions and once the variables are
gone right if we haven't recorded them
there's very little we can do right it's
a massive challenge to understand
how do we do our best with these limited
variables so we know there's confounding
factors and you know we didn't record
the weather outside but maybe it just
happened the weather affected that that
abducted a decision
and so I guess um
I'm curious to hear from you what have
been some of the big successes in RL um
classically
reinforcement learning started with
games so backgammon was probably the
first example of that uh and then uh
probably what people will will look at
next is actually the game of gold
um the so this program called alphago
was designed a deepmind
um in the UK and essentially
demonstrated that even though classic
computer programs
um struggle to play goal at any expert
level if we combine
expert data so basically Grand Master
goal games and we combine this with
reinforcement learning where the
learning agent got to play new games of
go and try out new things then this
resulted in a computer go player it was
much much stronger than anything we'd
seen before
um you know this is still board games
and the reason why games were the first
the first place where RL made progress
is because as we talked about even to
this day RL remains reason with data
inefficient but if you're in a game if
you can simulate the world then that's
very easy you just collect more data by
running more games right so actually in
2019 we applied reinforcement learning
through the problem of flying balloons
in a Stratosphere combined with a
company called loon that at a time was
using these balloons to deliver internet
in regions where there is no internet
connectivity okay
um
and one great challenge with these
balloon sisters that they they they're
very passively playing in the in the
stratosphere but you can still navigate
them a little bit by uh effectively
moving them up and down to to catch the
right lens and just to give you a sense
of the amount of data we needed to get
this to work first of all it took 40
days uh running 200 computers in Pilots
200 computer simulating flights and it
was about uh I think it's a billion
hours of flight time so it's a lot of
flight time you can imagine we couldn't
get this kind of data by flying anything
like real devices in the real world
right so uh still this was a success in
the sense that at the end of the project
I have a screenshot of those balloons
delivering internets over Kenya uh I
should print it and hang it on my wall
because I'm very proud of this of this
moment
but it was it was it was quite
challenging to get that way so since
then I think we've seen we've seen a few
more developments uh many of them coming
out of deepmind the discovery of
mathematical algorithms so how to better
do matrix multiplication well we can
actually use reimbursement into this and
uh I think we're just starting to see a
broadening of applications of RL into
new domains very interesting
wow okay
uh maybe you can tell me about
successful causality in causal learning
yeah it's interesting I see a lot of
parallels to both challenges that you're
describing in RL
um having to do with the limits of the
kinds of data that we can even gather
um and also in terms of being creative
about what kind of you know
data that you use to make these
conclusions so
um
from my perspective one of the biggest
successes in the field of causality I
think has to do with being able to
leverage natural experimentation and so
to explain that actually let me go back
a little bit further back and say that
one of the earliest successes of the
field of causality I would argue is a
recognition that actually we don't
always even have to do controlled
experiments
so for a lot of lab scientists it is
natural to think about holding every
variable fixed but manipulating one
thing and then seeing how the the system
changes and in fact that it's very
faithful to the way that I Define
interventions I was sort of saying all
else held fixed you manipulate one
variable and you see the effects the
probabilistic effects of doing that
intervention
but that's not even what we do mostly
when we do for example clinical trials
right so one of the first insights was
actually in fact that you can do causal
inference with randomized control trials
instead where in randomized control
trials we don't hold everything fixed
but changing one variable we instead we
randomly assign our intervention of
interest to groups of people in hopes
that then those two different groups of
people will become comparable
and the only difference that will then
remain that will explain the difference
in outcomes that we see for those groups
will be the effect of the treatment or
the intervention that we made and the
idea of making anything as random here
is because then you break the
relationship between those latent
factors that the doctors otherwise used
to make decisions right exactly and the
doctors actually comply with that
request of randomly assigning things
in practice absolutely not but because
of the kinds of Regulation that exist
around releasing new drugs we have to do
clinical trials so because of the
ability to do randomized control trials
before for example
um the development and deployment of
vaccines like we recently saw with kovid
um we have to do RCT
so I mean it's it's kind of it now
Looking Back Now that we do this
routinely it seems not so profound but
it was a profound moment in the history
of causality to recognize that you don't
have to do controlled experiments you
can do randomized control trials instead
but still this didn't help
causal inference take off in a lot of
the social sciences
the next Revolution came in I would say
around the 80s
um we now know this in economics as The
credibility Revolution and in fact in
2021 the Nobel prize in economics went
to causal inference researchers for
their work in
um natural experiments and in that field
they often call it quasi-experimental
methods
and this was a profound revolution in
the social sciences where now instead of
having to do rcts which is really hard
to do in economics you can't always uh
for example you're you're interested in
implementing the tax I cannot say I'm
going to randomly subject this half of
the audience to this tax and the rest of
you don't have to pay the tax and that's
how I will discover the impact of this
intervention on Behavior uh and it's so
instead the idea in economics that was
revolutionary was to use other sources
of exogenous variation we say exogenous
meaning sort of outside of the system
something changes and suddenly makes the
intervention behave as though it was
being randomly assigned so let me give
an example
um
for example uh
recently I was listening to a podcast
where in the Health Sciences somebody
was wondering about the causal effect of
breastfeeding on
cognitive development in dates in
infants
and um young children
and that's really hard to study
without
um or it's very hard to study with
clinical trials but what they did was
they looked at the facts that some
mothers give birth on weekends and some
others give birth on weekdays just due
to Natural variation and it just so
happens that there are fewer lactation
Consultants on the weekends and so this
reduces their exposure to
um lactation consultants and therefore
their ability to breastfeed goes down
and so now we get a natural experiment
that helps us disentangle the effects of
this intervention on outcomes even
though we didn't actually have a
randomized control trial
so that
idea of using heterogeneity of using
sort of other sources that induce
variation has been really profound in in
causal inference and
you know my feeling is that if we want
to bring these methods to bear on really
important decision-making problems that
we face today will need to kind of have
a similar type of credibility revolution
in the field of machine learning where
we exploit these kinds of insights that
have been developed in the field of
causality
um but combine them with the tools of ml
that allow us to infer variables from
really really complex inputs like we've
been talking about
maybe I
I still have a hard time sometimes
wrapping my head around
what causal reasoning is technically so
just maybe a technical clarification
quickly
um you talk about randomized control
trials and he said this was better than
a controlled experiment now I think of
our cities as a control experiment as
well what is a control experiment in
that language very okay great question
um
I'll go back and just make sure I was
really clear I am not saying it's better
than
um I'm saying it offers an alternative
too okay and so what is a control
experiment then great so in my view a
controlled experiment is every variable
is held fixed but on every sample you
intervene on only one variable that's
very costly and sometimes it's not
possible it's just not possible that's
right that's right yeah and so an
alternative would be you randomly assign
only the treatment variable of interest
so you don't get to control uh all the
other variables necessarily but you you
will then discover two groups of people
who are roughly the same just by random
chance right along all Dimensions that
may matter but they differ in the
treatment that they're exposed to it's
unlikely to happen and once you have a
lot of input environments right exactly
so maybe in the clinical example case we
can with this example I began with with
a simple new drug and a disease that it
may cure
um in practice what may be happening is
let's say we just observe a correlation
we see that whoever takes the drug uh
seems to have their chances of recovery
improve drastically right does can we
conclude a causal relationship from that
observation
not necessarily because it may turn out
as we look at more of the variables that
young people systematically chose to
take this treatment and they also had
all the right mechanisms and
propensities in place to have their
chances of recovery improve anyway
and so that's sort of the profound
challenge of causal imprints that
especially from non-experimental data
we can't tell apart whether a particular
Association that we see is due to a
causal relationship
or because some other variables are sort
of common causes of the treatment of
interest in the outcome of Interest
all right thanks yeah I'm going to jump
in this has been an absolutely
fascinating exploration of each of your
areas can we talk a little bit about the
intersection of causality and
reinforcement learning and I'll ask you
each to sort of think about the other
person's area and maybe give us some
examples of how some of the theories and
developments in each area can be applied
to your own work
I have to admit Dania and I sat down
last week to try to figure out exactly
what that intersection is and and
decided you know there is a website on
the internet called causal
reinforcementlearning.net but we still
don't quite understand everything
uh now this said I think it's obvious
from the language we're using that we we
both care about decisions and it's
almost a complementary perspectives on
how do we make these decisions uh you
know in a trustworthy way in a
statistically efficient way and how do
we collect the data uh talking about
randomized trials or exogenous variables
um I think reinforcement learning has
focused more traditionally on a Time
component I think it's interesting uh we
try to tease this apart a little bit
maybe don't even think we've thought
about this some more but you know what
is the role of time in physiology
because in RL it is it is a decorative
thing your animal lives in time and
evolves over time
yeah that's a that's a great question
and you know in a lot of the examples
that we give to motivate causality we
leave out time Mark is absolutely right
I would like to just make sure I give
credit to there's a large body of work
that has to do with sequential
interventions and uh temporal causal
imprints in fact there's a there's a
recent textbook from some amazing
Pioneers in this field Miguel Hernan and
Jamie Robbins on in particular exactly
this this topic this idea of temporal
and dynamic causal inference
um so time shows up in our study of
causality as well and
for example one of the things that I've
worked on has to do with confounding
problems that show up even in temporal
settings and one of the settings I've
looked at has to do with social networks
so we studied the question of can people
influence or rather
cause the behavior of their peers to
change
and there the issue is that you may
observe that yesterday Mark uh went to
packable and got a copy and today I did
the same thing
is it obvious that
um Mark caused me to do that
not necessarily uh and for a couple of
reasons so maybe pacvo is just in right
now we both just happened to go there
by coincidence
it could also be that Mark and I became
friends because we love Taco so much
right like this is this is the coffee
shop that we both live near and because
of that friendship it just so happened
that Mark went one day I went the next
day and that would have happened no
matter what
and so
even in temporal events
temporality is very nice because you
know causality you typically kind of
work in in linear time right we're not
um
sort of violating the laws of physics
here so typically For A Cause to be the
cause of an effect it should have
happened earlier in time but even so we
can we can't conclude just because thing
one happened and then thing two happened
the thing one cause thing too uh and so
there's a lot of work as well in that
context to disentangle causal effects
from from uh from correlation
but I think the
again
one of the nice things about causality
as a framework is that it provides a
language to make very mathematically
precise what is an intervention so it
allows us to take scientific questions
and turn them into math and it gives us
a calculus and reasoning tools
essentially
to be able to articulate assumptions
under which these causal quantities
could be inferred that we could draw
conclusions about them from a variety of
data but
what it doesn't give us is necessarily
satisfying tools to always do those
inferences with or rather for a variety
of causal questions like the one that I
alluded to earlier where we want to just
discover a causal model from data there
are a lot of impossibility results that
you cannot do it without some in
interventions
and so I think that's where
um you know I would I would really say
lies the intersection of causality and
RL
um I I don't think that for some of
these big decision-making problems that
we would like to tackle for example how
should we
for example develop interventions for
future pandemics or for really tackling
personalized medicine it's not going to
be possible without some experimentation
and
smart interventions and I think that's
where the mathematical
underpinnings
statistical work that's been developed
in RL will really be crucial for
making causality
which is a mathematical tool a practical
one
and I feel like it's connected to this
also briefly um
conversely I think most of the problems
we're reinforcement learning has had
success today or what we call fully
observable I know all of my variables
but the reality is almost all real
problems have unobserved variables and
the tools of Personality are exactly
there for us to reason about this right
and uh I think the reality is we haven't
really seen this at this intersection
materialized because it's it's you know
requires uh really literally bringing
two Fields together but I think it holds
so much promise
fabulous I think we have time for sort
of one more question up here and then
we're going to open it up to the
audience so I wanted to give everybody
sort of a heads up start thinking about
what kinds of questions remain
unanswered what kinds of new ideas have
come to your minds as we've been
listening to this fascinating
conversation and online as well too and
I'm sure if we if we didn't get it to
right now it would come up in the
questions and that is to explore the
topic of generative models and of course
chat gbt uh gpt4 now
um is drawing a lot of attention a lot
of discussion in the popular media in
the scientific media in policies circles
as well too and so I'd love to hear from
each of you
um you know what your perspective is on
this these new approaches these new
models that are coming forward and what
the opportunities are
to integrate or not in your own Fields
as well first yeah sure
um
I think the advances in generative
modeling has been obviously profound
what's interesting is that I think they
they kind of really challenge the
standard conventional machine learning
Paradigm that we
train on Independent samples that have
the same exact distribution and that we
you know learn these models that
potentially are memorizing all sorts of
spurious patterns
these models are are trained on lots and
lots and lots of sequential data they're
trained on data where humans are using
language I'm thinking now of Chad gbt in
particular
um where humans are using language to
describe potentially interventions that
they've taken on the world
humans are maybe describing changing
states of the world to these models
and so
I think it's not actually clear that you
know these models are actually even
being trained on independently
identically distributed samples anymore
they aren't right you know exactly
exactly
um I think also the facts that we can
interact with them often using natural
language to get them to do things
this is already a profound amount of
control that we have over these models
now we we are able to ask them to
manipulate certain variables in their
internal representation and give us
these very controlled changes
that being said I think that was that
was sort of the rosy View
I still think the problem is we don't
have the fine-grained control that we
think we do we would really want and
because of that mixed with the fact that
we've really I think don't understand
exactly what they're doing in order to
produce the outputs that they do there's
also a huge opportunity for
a lot of academic research here right in
understanding
um how to exert more fine-grained
control in order to
um make sure that we get outputs that
are not harmful or that exactly
regurgitate really dangerous human
cognitive patterns like we talked about
earlier
um and so I think what's exciting you
know sort of at the moment in time is
that I think they kind of break the mold
of conventional machine learning of
conventional causality and we in order
to study them better we potentially have
to really rethink our mathematical
foundations all together
um I might I don't know I'll I'll stick
with the maths that I know for now but
um
I agree with you I'm just absolutely
thrilled by what's happened in the last
few years in terms of just uh we were
talking about this before before uh
before starting today the fact that now
if I go to dinner on a Saturday night my
parents will ask me about Chad GPT and
not only that they've used it you know
they've tried it out and they can say
you know what do you think of this
um so that's absolutely exciting but you
know bringing it back into this
discussion today about agents and and
how what do we expect intelligence
agents to do
thing one thing is the general modeling
doesn't do on its own is make the right
decisions right like if you if you to
use the chat GPT example if you've
learned to speak from the entirety of
the internet it doesn't mean you're
going to say the right things when you
talk to somebody and actually we see
this even in classic we were talking
about go playing earlier right alphago
was first trained on the best human
players on all of their games and
actually what you get out of this is a
pretty good go player it's it's a system
that would defeat me easily if I was to
play golf but then what we want to do is
take this as a starting point and say
okay that's that's a nice fire a nice
mold to talk to start from but now what
we really want to do is explore the
consequences of those decisions in a way
that's a bit more reasonable right if
we're using reinforcement learning it's
going to mean to to explore new ways of
Behaving and try to figure out the the
way they plan out and I guess in terms
of the cause of learning we're also
going to need to reason about possibly
confounding variables
absolutely absolutely and I think you
know if we want them for example to
apply causal reasoning there's going to
be a lot of interesting work I think in
how do we teach them that right right
like uh they're they're it's not that
us as humans inherently know how to
work with causality of the mathematical
framework and reason we're taught to do
it yeah you know we have a teacher or
somebody that explains to us that uh
correlation is not causation and so I
think
you know the fact that we we do get to
interact with these things using
language is very interesting and
presents an exciting opportunity the
fact that we can ask them to reason step
by step and they will change their
behavior uh even within a particular
prompt it's
obviously profound but also presents
like an interesting opportunity on okay
then how do we teach them useful
reasoning tools
a whole new field of intelligent agents
has has opened up for us and it's it is
it's a huge opportunity for research and
Innovation and advancing science
um and for for new applications as well
too okay so let's open it up to the room
Kathleen's got the microphone I'm gonna
I knew I was gonna see Gail's hand up
first keep your hands up and we'll bring
it around to you I'm going to do one in
person and then go to Kira online next
so Kathleen you're gonna have to run
perfect thanks I think wearing my yellow
shirt paid off here just um so you've
elegantly spoken about the need to
interact with the world to interrogate
its causality and we just touched on the
notion of generative Ai and I was
wondering if
One Way forward with these capabilities
you know generative AI right now is is
trying to
generate stuff that's consistent with
some uh distribution right but you think
you know you know where I've gone with
this right can we use these types of
capabilities to probe uh and interact
with the world or you know how do you
kind of mesh generative possibilities
with reinforcement learning and causing
in causal modeling is that where we're
going
yeah maybe I can start here I think it's
a great question can we can we use those
racing tools to then get more data
essentially right and I think
I mean on one hand yes so what is chat
GPT but an interface that can speak to
humans and then figure out how humans
feel about this in GPT is trained with
reinforcement learning based on feedback
from humans but
uh these are completely different pieces
of software right like there's one piece
of software and one neural network for
absorbing a given data set and turning
it into uh you know a generative model
of language and there's a completely
different piece of software that's a
chat box that you can type things in and
interact with the internet and I think
John Schulman who who you know led the
team that built chat GPT said this on
Twitter he said it turns out a lot of
reinforcement learning was building chat
boxes it has nothing to do with you know
a better algorithm
yeah I I I'm going to answer that from a
different slightly different perspective
which is
um
given that these algorithms
are able to
sort of shift
so richly to our requests in natural
language right I can ask it okay here's
this in this text
um rewrite the same thing for me but in
a more formal way
um is pretty profound because for a long
time in the field of puzzle inference we
thought well
um it's going to be really hard we don't
have the regenerative models to be able
to
control our system so well that we can
get these kind of counter factual pieces
of text where most factors stay fixed
but only a few change
that is now profoundly not true we can
we can definitely do this potentially
with chat GPT but I think what then
constitutes really exciting research is
do we actually have that fine-grained
control over these systems and in fact
when we when we tell chat gbt uh let's
play a game where you pretend like
you're a lawyer and rewrite these
rewrite this text
um
do we know exactly which factors are
being held fixed and which ones are
changing that will have a profound
consequence on
the causal inferences that we would draw
and so I think that yes there's a very
big opportunity with generative Ai and
using them to actually do interventions
on the world
but I think that the research that needs
to be done is understanding more how
exactly they are implementing those
interventions and whether they
correspond to the intervention that I
had imagined
because that that mismatch could
definitely lead to a lot of biases in
Downstream conclusions
so it's definitely some uncertainties
and some risks as well there too okay
Kira give us a question from our online
okay thanks we have a few questions I'll
start um as the voice of the online
audience you have a question from Joshua
benjio
um which is you have not talked about a
major difference between most of RL and
most of causality which is Ms of RL is
model free well most of causality is
model based um any comment and I'll just
add there was also a question about the
difficulties in evaluating causal models
that is a bit related so if you could
address those thank you maybe I can
start with the definition of model Queen
model based uh
if I go but what you're asked uh he's
right at it you know classically in RL
what we've studied is model pre-learning
which is essentially
um you know read and learn a complete uh
description of how my world operates I'm
just going to learn to react a little
bit like a Pavlov's dog I'm going to
learn to react and if I get more data I
consume it right away and then it's
discarded and the model free version
would be where I actually do learn I try
to predict the outcome of my actions
store this somewhere in memory and then
use this later you know to draw cause of
influences now the distinction is
actually quite blurry in practice but
maybe Daniel you have an answer to me
why why is causal learning not model
free
that's a that's a great question and I
would like to
Echo a little bit of what you said that
the distinction is not actually all that
clear
um and you know I'd like to to challenge
this convention that you know causal
inference is necessarily model based I
think the way in which it's model based
is of course
um we we will specify a number of
variables and we will maybe positive
causal model over them and ask questions
or we will say ah from data I would like
to discover some causal model
there's a way too in which uh causality
isn't necessarily concerned with
parametric assumptions and so in machine
learning or in statistics we will say
um you know parametric assumptions are
us committing to a specific type of
model when we want to fit our data and
there's a lot of work in causality that
actually sets those aside and instead
tries to figure out how can we use our
data as agnostically as possible
so I I feel that especially in in the
field of causal inference this exact
distinction of model free model based is
I would say a little blurry
and I think to Joshua's question is to
why RL
has been model 3 or is often model free
I think this this the same way there is
a computational question which we don't
really have
you know research is often about
planning Pathways that work props where
it allow us to do do things and and
while we've made great progress in terms
of learning these these rich
descriptions of the world and predicting
what's going to happen in the future it
still feels like it's not completely
there for much larger problems where
we've already seen model 3 learning give
us some some results
so thank you both for those answers uh
next question from the audience
for the discussion uh I was wondering
one of my main
um
sure one of my main interest researching
Chris is actually Joe
um cultural relevancy in the context of
fairness and robustness and I was uh
thinking that the intersection of RL and
causality would be great uh intersection
to explore for uh various correlations
and I was wondering what is your
um idea what is your opinion on that
thanks
maybe I can say so I actually agree with
you that this is an incredibly important
intersection
um
maybe unfortunately research you haven't
seen much done in that space uh maybe in
part because in recent years especially
a lot of the work we've done has been in
sort of domains you know an application
of reimbursement to controlling a
physical system like a fusion reactor
maybe these questions aren't as pressing
but obviously as we bring this into real
world you know we should make the step
of mind and uh
I was at the talk just a few days ago
where people were demonstrating a very
large robotic system and somebody said
exactly this that you know you should be
considering
how you train this robot to understand
natural language
and even though some people thought well
it's still early I think it's never too
early to start anybody's questions
I uh I'd like to just Begin by saying
you you touched on an excellent insight
and you're absolutely right so there is
starting to be a lot there's starting to
be a field uh that that specifically
considers the role of causal models in
making algorithmic decision making more
fair and a lot of this work has indeed
uh been about positing models of
decision making and saying
um ah the naive models are are sensitive
to these kinds of spurious associations
and stereotypes but a causal model would
not be and considers how would we train
our machine learning methods to behave
more like these causal models you're
absolutely right
um and I think this this field has a lot
more work to do to develop and
especially in the context of of systems
like large language models and
generative AI
um
from a very very different perspective I
I also want to just kind of give a shout
out to the facts that uh part of this
doing this research really successfully
is to make sure we have a really diverse
group of people included in AI right
like like representation and different
perspectives is what actually brings
research forward especially in fields
like uh bias and fairness and ethical AI
I think everybody when we have a richer
group of people at play at the table uh
provide amazing perspectives especially
on those kinds of topics amazing I have
time for one more short question and
short answer as well too please go ahead
thank you for the very interesting
conversation
um so well to me at least it appears
that an RL agent is implicitly trying to
solve a causal model through the credit
assignment problem and I was wondering
maybe like the connection is in fact
closer and we could use RL to do causal
inference
in some sense
um so the question dependency correctly
was can we use RL to do causal inference
and RL agents are learning causal models
maybe Daniel let you take this one and
if you have a Concrete technical answer
for us so can you actually uh tell me a
little bit about credit assignment yeah
so that was the core of the question
here
um
and reinforcement learning specifically
well
I think as we talked about reinforcement
learning is often about time and so in
that sense you know there's a causal
relationship with it
as we said earlier I think once you move
to domains where there's latent
variables and variables that are not
observed the reality is we haven't
really developed the tools then
reinforcement and proper to deal with
these issues and if you return to causal
learning you know at a different level
than just think about time that makes
sense
and maybe to just tackle the the last
part of that question of can RL be used
to help causal influence I mean at a
high level I suspect yeah probably but I
I do think on a more technical level
um the exact methods that probably the
field of RL has developed so far are to
to infer good policies
may need to be adapted a little bit to
meet the goals of causal inference uh
because for example the exact uh goal of
a policy to maximize expected rewards
wouldn't fit
literally into the Paradigm of causal
inference but that being said I think in
terms of drawing connections between
these two Fields absolutely there's
opportunities amazing I'm I'm so
disappointed that we have to end this
conversation now but the people in the
room have the opportunity to continue it
uh with us in a in a less formal setting
so uh please join me everybody in uh
thanking Mark and Donya for their
amazing exploration of these of these
topics today I also want to invite all
of you to see far's next talk in this
series which is happening at May 11th at
noon Eastern Time
with the title appeals to human dignity
does it make a difference this is
looking more at social sciences and it
will feature will kimluka and Evan
Lieberman of cfar's boundaries
membership and belonging program and
last but not least uh remind you to
visit cfar's website to get the video
from from this event but also to see
further details on our future virtual
talks thank you everyone thank you very
much to our speakers and to our online
audience and have a wonderful day thank
you thank you
foreign
[Music]